like I I posted about something critical
about public schools the other day about
how they're teaching Marxism to our kids
and somebody commented and said they
don't teach Marxism at Public Schools
I'm like you don't explicitly have to
give out a book by Marx to be teaching
Marxism it's this idea of this oppressor
versus this oppressed thing this
critical theory thing and when you just
Ram that down people's heads you end up
like militarizing and radicalizing an
entire generation yeah they indoctrinate
people with Marxism they don't
unfortunately as far as I know actually
teach the theories of Marxism enough
they should probably teach that more so
that you can realize if were being
indoctrinated no no teaching public
school if they taught actual Marxist
theory along with history of Marxism the
children would be crying by the end of
the day and say why would anyone ever do
such a thing those poor people the
hundred 100 million who are 1958 1962
Great Leap Forward 100 million it's so
easy to be like we're all in this
together let's go all of us and then
once the revolution happens it's likeis
killed more between 1958 and 1962 than
white supremacism did between 1619 and